so
[Music]
hmm
interesting hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to tealerland
it's been a while since i played a five
nights at freddy's fan game and this
game came out a month or two ago and it
seemed to have some interesting elements
that i have not often seen in these
types of games before but let's see what
taylor land is all about
i'm curious
[Music]
years have passed since the unfortunate
closure of the tealerland amusement park
founded by you david david along with
your brother teal thought i had more
time since then you've both moved on and
gone separate ways
oh
after all this time the park still
stands abandoned untouched
until now
hello
hi
mine
well this is kind of intense
it's a bit more intense than i thought
it might be very interesting
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the thing about five nancy
freddy's fame games sometimes you find
one that just has
polish now i don't know if the game
itself has polished but if this is how
much work is put into just the cinematic
i'm actually kind of impressed
this is not bad
welcome to tealerland now abandoned
lifeless amusement park untouched
unwanted to navigate within your
environment use was mouse to look around
left click to interact
what
oh that's fun when you're ready to go
beneath
find a way into the storage facility
hiding below
an entrance dilapidated sign shines at
the tops by years of wear
who's paying the power bill
certainly not me
all right
no s
hi what appears to be a cardboard cut
out of the park's mascot okay so i i see
a problem right off the bat this was
never appealing this was always
horrifying
very interesting an out-of-order teacup
ride the rain has damaged some of the
paint
all right
hey
[ __ ]
what you do in there i don't have
anything to say about that nobody's here
yeah i didn't notice the big lumbering
behemoth that slunked out a frame all
right
large statue of taylor good god polished
in a fine golden paint to welcome guests
that thing's huge
all right whatever
okay
cool i'll just keep going forward then
a group of rather suspiciously placed
trash bags it's likely that something is
hidden beneath them oh i wonder i wonder
where the entrance could possibly be
okay
all
ah right at that very convenient
this is weird it's got like a bit of um
uh
ex mortis feel to it you know what i
mean
you guys remember ex mortis the flash
game oh fun climb down the ladder with s
and look around with the mouse when not
climbing your flashlight will activate
after a short cool bound period when the
flashlight is on and tealer is
[Music]
oh oh we're going right now
dealers
all right
hi dealer
oh we're going right now
right now is when we're gonna go
aha
right
good thing he's scared of a flashlight
hey bud all right you're not so scary
hey hey hey
you big [ __ ]
you big [ __ ] you oh
hey
get out of here you what a scamp
oh oh oh oh oh this is the level select
scoop uh oh pb 187 seconds oh custom oh
i'm gonna go back here i just want to
see something real quick
[Music]
peekaboo
oh
god
wow that's great okay i'm gonna go back
now all right tutorial times are not
recorded for this level
great i have a funny feeling i need to
learn a lot because this seems
complicated player lure movement
restart interact gather heal assemble
heal oh boy
okay including willow i don't know who
willow is
oh here i am you're currently in the
control room which is one of the three
main rooms you can travel between no
enemies are active during this night so
take time to explore
use the wasd and e keys you can move or
interact within your environment from
here you can access the main computer
the left side door or your checklist
needs
assembly objective find the supplies
room far left the hall and control room
i don't know what the hell is going on
oh no what the hell you talking about
all right wait let me see this oh no
signal detected please check if t-lure
is assembled correctly
i don't know where the t-lure is when
your lure is assembled it will let you
control it as well as show the map of
the entire facility you will want to
come back after you have assembled the
lure as until then you cannot access the
computer's interface
okay
i'm on my way going through the store
will lead you to the main hall when next
to a door remember to check the keyhole
before going through by pressing e to
make sure nothing's outside
i can't tell if there's anything there
i'm gonna guess no
oh
a little map up there too main hall the
door on your left leads to supplies
threats can enter through the hall and
you defend against them the same way you
do if you see them in the keyhole here
growling move to another room no audible
growling noise stay still and stare
okay
right
the supplies room is where you assemble
the lure robot each night this uses spot
to lead enemies into their containment
rooms thus completing the night find
spare parts that randomly spawn any
other floor click to gather them click
and hold the lure about to apply the
piece after three pieces
complete
okay that looked like an arm but okay i
need to find more parts on the ground
looking through
and
great oh part
all right
oh part no no part
not a part
oh hard
oh
hi
now that your lure is up and running you
will need to access and control it by
going to your computer in the control
room when threats are active be sure to
move as quickly as possible to control
room to prevent risk of the lure being
attacked before you're able to control
it
great
ah oh
it's gone
okay
like i said
complicated
oh no
looks like your lure got corrupted
remember to always move your lure back
and forth when near a threat to prevent
getting corrupted fix lure go to supply
room
what
oh god
oh
what do you mean
firewall
[Music]
corrupted files always start with zany
okay
nice work after the tutorial now
remember that you will only have a
limited amount of time to fix your lure
before it becomes fully corrupt
right
okay
why am i here move
to continue
uh
core
lure the training dummy into one of the
containment doors
oh
i'm lured
okay
oh
great job in the event and an
animatronic attacks here takes away some
of your hp you can regain it with the
one-time use syringe located in the
supply room med kit you've now learned
the basic congratulations you can click
on the task in the checklist and proceed
to the next level select
okay
learn the ropes i have learned the ropes
i thought
but did i though but did i though but
did i though
[Applause]
okay
oh boy
oh
boy i don't know what i'm doing
i don't know anything about what i'm
doing
i don't know what i'm doing
here we go
okay
assemble it i need to assemble the lure
every time that's what i'm getting from
this i don't really know
what the lord does
nothing
hi
buddy great
is there something there
no way jose
[Music]
oh god oh god oh god oh god
i didn't know if i was supposed to stare
or not
well that hurt i'm gonna heal
my hp is
nothing like some sweet heroine to ease
the pain
all right that was great
oh god oh god what do i do i'm leaving
i'm leaving
what do i do contain dealer how
hello
okay i'm not
just gonna not
this is great where's there's that last
piece
all right and we're up and running i
think
firewall looking good
okay
all right well
that's great
uh
hey pal you want to come over here buddy
you want to be lured
corruption is occurring
come on
oh god oh god okay what do i do about
that oh god what do i do about that oh
what have i done
what is happening
did you get corrupted ah shoot i got
corrupted
here we go whoa
firewalls annie
i'm going i'm going i'm leaving i don't
know what that was i don't care shut up
all right this is great all right come
here you let's get you out of here
let's continue
nice
what is this about
what is with that guy
okay am i done i did it i think i did it
welp job done
what did i do
i contained the tealer
wow
i did it
with enough effort
you
that is an unhealthy way to look at your
surroundings and the people around you
what
hmm
you've unlocked a few character
descriptions
great
hi tealer healer is the titular
character of tailorland park his
character is depicted as a gray dragon
with a jester outfit the axe is part of
the outfit him along with the others
were constructed by david artel he is
one of the many lurable threats that
lurk in the underground facility and one
of the first to activate within each
hour he will try to make his way towards
the main hall and then one of the key
holes upon his arrival do not stay in
the same room or stay in the keyhole for
too long to avoid getting attacked he is
the slowest to lure out of all the
threats if the lure stays still for too
long within taylor's range taylor will
proceed to infect the lure forcing the
player to use a firewall
great
i'm guessing we have a new friend
all right frill
frittle my boy
stop looking at that you idiot
all right again nothing
easy oh that was a piece
i shouldn't have just
i shouldn't have just looked
[Applause]
nothing
i'm a god
i'm a goddamn genius
easy easy easy easy got it lure lure
baby lure
lure baby
no you don't not today
stop you won't stop no you can't
you can't oh yeah you're lord oh god oh
that doesn't sound good oh that don't
sound good
oh that sounds
bad okay oh god oh god
what
what is it
yeah get out of here i was just guessing
that that was what i needed to do you
dill weed
oh that doesn't sound good
that was a little bit
no no no no oh
oh what happened
that's a way
hey
screw you
that's what i thought
better not corrupt my dude ah there you
are
okay this is an interesting mechanic i
gotta admit you know i'll be the first
to admit
this thing kind of is cool
it's kind of dope
okay can you get in there oh do i have
to
what
oh do you have a different control i bet
ah you have a different containment room
okay that makes sense
now you can't escape me it's like a game
of chess here
did i just let
the other one out
i hope i didn't okay no i did i didn't
i did it i'm a goddamn god boing point
done get out of here
love it check check check check
god i'm good at this game
i got a perk point i should spend my
perk points
i should spend my perk points his
machines
have far greater potential
than what they were made for
sitting in this facility
rotting away
[Music]
thank you
why are you talking over the
loudspeakers
oh
that's a triceratops that's a
triceratops
okay
all right
willow
is that who you were willow is an
ambient threat within the facility her
character depicts a red and white wyvern
with a magician outfit ambient threats
are unable to be lured oh ah so the
yellow ones cannot be lured regular make
your way into the hall so you can even
go to the hall even if threats besides
steeler are already there which around
people laugh you'll limit out time to go
in the halls oh i have to stare at her
in the hall
frill
lizard with knight's armor has ability
to infect the lure
aha okay so bang on the door until you
look through the keyhole okay so but
will not attack
i see
all right hour three it is get ready to
get fricked get fresh right in your
right frick hole
that sounded bad
nothing
like the [ __ ] it is
as i suspected previously
give me that
i'm a god at
this nothing that's what i thought
begin the luring
no no no you come back oh god oh god
what is that what is that fuel
was that fuel
oh that's not good
oh
god here i am shut up i'm luring oh wait
hang on wait no hang on okay
yeah what is it
what is it oh
i think it's been infected
oh god i think i need to go out and
stare no
oh firewall
zany oh that's that sounds bad
i'm staring at you i'm staring at you
i'm staring at you
okay a lot going on here locko and i
have fuel for some reason i don't know
why i have fuel
facilities power becomes faulty lure has
access to the jet oh god i have to are
you kidding me
are you kidding me
okay well that's one
okay you're there which is good
come on you're you're lord yeah yeah yo
okay oh god oh god what's happening oh
god oh god oh god i'm doomed i'm doing
i'm doing wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait stop nope hang on what what what
[Music]
i guessed right i guess correctly oh god
no
i'm staring
firewalls annie
oh god this is complicated but that's
okay
okay see the generator meter on the left
if it depletes i gotta go okay
wait oh god it's the thing no no no hang
on don't don't unlure don't unlur why
does it take so long
god i gotta re-lure you oh god
okay come with me come with me you're
going to jail you're going to naughty
jail
you're going to
they're going to horny jail get out of
here okay uh
well i'm done
i'm i'm i'm done it's amazing that i get
decide when i'm done does that mean i
could just leave right off the bat could
i check them all off
i didn't spend my perks blam
no also who are you who you did i made
these things i made them you didn't make
them i made them so shut up
casey
uh
mischievous huh okay all right works
right longer lure infection cooldown
after using firewall i don't need easier
to spot that's dumb
four each
increase the speed of map doors opening
max hp lures range of view
lore movement speed that's probably the
best one i'm gonna save up one more and
get that one
oh hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa
i'm done ah [ __ ] i was worth a try
wait no i don't need to do that
[Music]
i like that it doesn't last a certain
amount of time because then i'm done
whenever i'm done and my skill is what
oh oh god oh god i'm leaving
oh god i
left lure
lure me
luring
oh that doesn't sound good oh that
sounds bad oh god that sounds bad okay
your lord come with me hang on i'll be
right with you
i'll be right with you pal
all right that's one down on me
can i help you
oh don't like that
oh that's not good what's happening
oh
can i lure you pal oh who's jiggling my
handle
why
hi oh it's you
and i gotta check the firewall what is
on the ground there
what what is on the ground there
oh
no i'm looking away that's right not you
no no no no no no
no
all right and totally clear
all right let's get this bad boy going
i'm almost out of generator
oh no
did one of you break the other dude out
you did didn't you you [ __ ]
come here
can your got
great
oh that's not good oh that's that's the
opposite of good okay that's that's bad
hi
how are you doing
i'm here i'm staring i'm going back in
well that can be hey hey don't you do
nothing are you breaking them out oh
it's a lot of noises happening
come on
wait wait wait wait oh god oh i already
oh
duh
there we go
okay
i did it oh why do i have an alert here
hello why are you jiggling my handle
stop it what's going on in here lore
that's what's happening
interesting well guess i'm done here
i'm a god i'm a god amongst mere mortals
i'm a stunning
king
[Applause]
excellent one more step
until the plan is complete
the clock
is ticking are you doing this while i'm
here while i'm in here are you doing all
this
because that's kind of mean oh oh that
is some lore all right so anyone who
wants to know the lore there you go oh
hey oh i can only grab one lore per
night i see mischievous
i don't like your eyes
never go towards keyholes
[Music]
the doll the the doll
the doll okay so i gotta find it and
click on it is what you're saying
this is too much to know this is too
much to learn this is too much to keep
in my tiny brain actually my brain's
huge that's why my head's so big and
that's the only reason everyone else
shut up
okay here we go
i love building the lure
i hear that
oh hey pal
[Music]
oh
my god
okay hey pal what's going on friend hey
how you doing
hey come on no be nice be nice be nice
be nice
that's right that's right that's right
that's how we do oh god oh god that
sounds bad hang on hang on hang on hang
on hang on hang on oh god did i get it i
don't know did i get it hi
hey what's up i think you're good
oh god what do you mean
what do you mean i'm staring at you
[Music]
what is
ow
my blood
all of my blood how do i fix the
generator
i don't know
oh god hi i'm almost dead now thank you
for all of that you've done for me
i fixed the generator i fixed it did you
know i fixed it because i did you guys
jailbreak yourselves
that's a real dick move
okay hi yes
hi
i need to get to the
thing
hello go away
okay a lot of beep blanking going on
around here
oh my god
okay so that was uh healer land i
think that's fascinating finale yeah
right
finale oh man i need to do some research
because the only reason i was getting by
that is because i was just getting lucky
so uh yeah if you guys want to check out
this game definitely check it out link
is in the description yeah and let me
know if you want me to finish this
because i was kind of fascinating and
also i forgot to get my perk of
faster lure speed which i'm sure was
incredibly valuable and will definitely
help me
oh unlocking my first perk thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed it check out more five nights at
freddy's fan games i played in the
playlist available in the description
check out distractible if you haven't
heard of it already it's my podcast with
bob and wade and thank you again and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye bye
[Music]